thanks for joining us America in the
lobby of financial peace Plaza right
here in Martha's place is Lauren hi
Lauren welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
I'm so excited to be here we're so
excited to have you where are you from
Columbia South Carolina that's a bit of
a drive to Nashville what about seven
hours about seven hours okay very cool
well it's good to have you I assume
you're here to do your debt-free scream
oh yes sir I love it and how much have
you paid off we've paid off a grand
total of a hundred and five thousand
dollars in four years
way to go I love it very cool making
what kind of money during that time
seventy-five thousand Wow we went from
an income of 60,000 to 75,000 excellent
very good good for you what kind of debt
was the hundred and five mortgage on the
house you paid off your house hey how
old are you
thirty years old dang my gosh you're so
weird I am weird I love it
that's what God has started in the first
place day four years ago you're 26 years
old what happens it makes you believe
you can pay off your house because
everybody knows that you can't get ahead
in the American economy I mean there's
structural problems in the economy you
can't win and yet you went and paid off
your house of course well Dave it all
started back in 2006 when Jay and I
first got married we saw your banner on
Winthrop University's campus he was
doing his MBA in Business and Finance
and it said normal is broke be weird
there you go and we researched that
saying and found out that it was you and
your principles behind what we do here
and decided to get on board with your
program because we had a we had an
overall goal of wanting to live and give
like no one else there you go
I love that what a great goal alright so
for years so twenty-five thousand
dollars a year out of a seventy-five or
a sixty thousand dollar income depending
on what
here we look at this you guys have
really watched what you're doing I mean
you've been on beans and rice I bet
people made fun of Dave we we had some
some lookers there that were really
questionable about what we were doing
now that the house is paid off and
you're only 30 years old I bet they're
believers now I think they are at least
at least that's the ultimate way to give
them a shut up seriously I love it gives
you a long way well and then you got the
rest of your life with not a payment in
the world that's right Dave if you can't
build wealth and you can't give in that
scenario something seriously wrong with
you that's amazing well congratulations
I'm very proud of you you got to feel
great what do you tell people the secret
to getting out of that is the secret to
getting out of debt is discipline you
really have to be disciplined in what
you're doing and you have to make a plan
are you naturally disciplined to begin
with no what made you disciplined
because most people say I'm not
disciplined when they hear that they say
I can't do it then you know but but you
became disciplined what how did you do
that having a goal really helps me to
become disciplined you go and also
what's been going on for the past five
years really my husband was diagnosed
with a brain tumor in 2008 a year and a
half into our marriage Wow and Dave we
were really glad that we started with
your principles to begin with that early
on in our marriage we had built up an
emergency fund which was baby step one
we were living with his parents in the
basement of their house and so glad that
when that diagnosis came and the medical
bills started rolling in we were able to
use that emergency fund to not go into
debt medically and still start saving
and putting towards our retirement
accounts and then we really had to sit
down and take a look because his
diagnosis meant having continuous
medical bill
for the rest of his life oh really he
passed away in April we really sat down
after he got diagnosed and said well
okay we have to plan out financially for
what's gonna happen medically mm-hmm we
just started putting aside money for
that type of emergency fund as well as
funding an emergency fund so planning
for a plan and as well as paying double
our house payment during that time as
well Wow and so you guys are fighting
that fight with him I mean while he's
fighting a fight for you so that he
leaves you debt-free that was his legacy
that he wanted to leave he need to make
sure he did what a wonderful legacy so
when was the house paid off August 28th
that was just shy of four years before
our first house payment in just a few
months after he passes we had we had
made our plan at the beginning of this
year to become debt-free in June Dave
uh-huh and he passed in April I needed
to use some of our emergency fund to
take care of funeral expenses so I had
to put that off until August right
we were $11,000 to go before paying off
the house when he passed and August came
and I did it there you go
I did it well and you and I both know
he's watching the whole time he is then
screaming and screaming debt-free with
us right now
absence amazing absolutely Wow Wow how
old was he
30 years old 30 years all same age oh my
goodness that is the most heartbreaking
and victorious story all at the same
time you're amazing amazing that's an
amazing story thank you and you are set
for the rest of your life I am I am and
my goodness you do all this before
you're 30 you can do anything there's
nothing to stop you I mean yeah I mean
that that much that much life already
lived yeah you are you're what we call
tough now oh my goodness I'm so proud of
you God's good
Dave yes he is so good his provisions
you know never never fail no I don't
never fail absolutely amazing what was
your husband's name
Jay Jay aha all right well Jay and
Lauren have paid off their home in
August it's all paid for
I absolutely love it a hundred and five
thousand dollars paid off in four years
making seventy five thousand dollars a
year by the time she's 30 years old by
the time he's 30 years old count it down
let's hear a great debt free scream
three two
[Applause]
Wow unbelievable
everybody's cheering and crying at the
same time out there in Martha's place
unbelievable I don't really have
anything to say I can't breathe you're
incredible Lauren absolutely incredible
Wow all I can say is is that if she can
do it and they can do it in that
situation you got no excuses you can sit
around and listen to people who say
ridiculous things like the economy is
structurally flawed and the political
system is stacked against you and all
these moronic academic viewpoints that
are simply not true or you can be
introduced to Lauren who believes that
her destiny is in her control and she
and her husband their faith in
themselves their faith in God their
faith in common sense financial
principles put him in this situation
that story could have been written a lot
of different ways she could have been a
victim she had a lot of reasons to call
herself a victim you don't get
inspiration from that you don't have a
heart in your chest this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]
you